now um then second announcement this
tutorial is slightly different than the
ones we used to give uh beforehand if
you come to a tutorial about image
processing and Mathematica it was
basically Mathematica that I would talk
about and uh all the great features of
Mathematica and explain what we have
show the scope and so forth now we
noticed that there are quite a few
Mathematica users out there uh who love
to do a little bit of image processing
but don't have any background on image
processing so this talk is slightly
different it doesn't it assumes to a
certain degree that you know Mathematica
and I now just like to show you how you
do math uh image processing what kind of
tools you have what's possible and where
things get difficult because the
standard uh experiences that you get
started and you think it's easy and then
very quickly find out that things don't
work the way you anticipate they should
work uh and unfortunately you're working
with real data and real data never comes
the way uh theoretically it should be
and uh so uh I just Tred to show you a
few things to get going on that track
this is a kind of a test run for a
larger kind of Workshop because I only
have one hour and one hour is way too
short to get anything really done so uh
bear with me I'm going to jump across
and this is just a very small excerpt of
what will be a larger tutorial the next
one will be in Amsterdam on the 17th and
18th of June and then we'll have a
webinar version and eventually we have a
big webinar version of this uh out on
the web all right uh well that was
abstract we'll just skip this uh quickly
an overview uh I will follow somewhat
the classical path into U image
processing that would basically be first
some Basics what is the object that
represents an image and so forth then
I'll be talking about filtering
regularizing images uh getting rid of
the noise in an image and so forth and
then the first big topic is segmentation
how to identify Parts in an image uh
then once you have done that the next
natural step would be morphology how to
uh twist or how to get what you found in
the right shape or measure make
measurements on it uh and then last but
not least I'll talk about registration
uh in case it doesn't ring a bell
registration is the art and image
processing processing of having two
images and trying to get them
congruently on top of each other so if
you have uh let's say a pet scan and an
MRI scan in medicine you may have the
same object and then you try to get the
data on top of of each other or if you
have two photographs and you would like
to make a big scenery that's called
stitching you have to get the overlap of
those two images and uh make them
fit all right um so let's not waste any
time five minutes into the hour um first
some Basics now if you use Mathematica
um You probably forgot some of the
computer Basics which is what data type
are you using and so forth because you
don't have to worry about it anymore
that's not quite true in in uh image
processing because images are really
stored in just one bite per pixel or bit
16 implementation and so forth so I will
spend a little bit the first 5 to 10
minutes on some Basics about the uh
image implementation in Mathematica
which may be boring but it will turn out
to be essential once you do some work in
Mathematica okay first of all trivial
thing anything you create in Mathematica
beat an array 2D 3D you can convert into
an image by simply plugging it into the
image object which is also its own
Creator so you just have let's say here
in this case um an image potentially
with three channels you define a color
space and just by typing this into
Mathematica you create an image
hopefully and this this little spec
there at the very bottom uh that's now
your 2 * 3 pixel image now that's one
way to create or import images another
way of course is to just tap into the uh
example database in Mathematica to uh
generate images if you don't have one at
hand for example if you don't have a 3D
Volume uh which I may not get now
because let's see am I
connected I may have to
go uh let me try once again because I'm
working I think on a development version
and for development oh there we go okay
uh I have to have VPN access uh
okay so this would give you then a
sample object in this case a 3D object
which is also considered an image from
my perspective uh which you can nicely
view you can rotate you can change all
kinds of aspects of the visualization of
this which I'll skip right now and then
last but not least you can get uh data
from anywhere uh from local files from
remote files so if I would basically
here tap on the web page for this
conference I would be able to get a
conference image just like that into
Mathematica so it's no big deal to get
the images in and once you have the
images in you can work on them you can
ask for all kinds of properties um like
image dimension of the volume I just had
it's a 256 times 256 times 110 uh voxel
volume uh you can ask about how many
image channels that one image I had I
was generating three images three
channels then the color space you have
and then if you want to be more precise
you can even uh um extract the uh
so-called color profile for an image
which is a bit more specific on how the
color is encoded I mean the image
internally is just a set of numbers and
then you have to have a translation and
how that number is uh displayed as a
color and that can be device dependent
uh and for all these device dependent U
uh color uh spaces you have color data
profile data and they usually come with
the image otherwise you can generate
them in
Mathematica uh usually a volume has just
one ch Channel basically encoding having
kind of an index encoding which means uh
you have to translate just one number
into a corresponding color and the
corresponding command for uh 2D images
would be colorized you can just say here
I have a image which initially is
grayscale because it just has values
between 0 and 255 per pixel and I can
just say oh translate that please via
color function into let's say this kind
of U construct uh and then you get a
different coloring of that image and the
same holds true of course for 3D volumes
but there there's one additional uh
feature and that is you not only specify
the color but also the opacity the
translucence the transparency of that
voxel and that makes it uh clear if you
can look through that voxel or not which
is essential for 3D and the what you
then specify it's called a transfer
function or in mathematical terms it's a
color function and here you can specify
for example via blend a color function
that says well if you come in with zero
you basically have a completely
transparent uh voxel voxel with a value
of 0.03 uh is less transparent has a
little bit of radish in there and here
you get more and more opaque colors
until you hit orange and that eventually
will render now the uh previous volume
here in a more Rusty color so it's a
rusty engine uh on a uh greenish
background and last but not least U
images tend to come with all kinds of
extra information that you could also
utilize in Mathematica this one was
taken from the last conference in uh in
London where we had a spectacular view
from the canary Warf uh onto the city of
London and uh took this image and here
you can see that I used my little iPad
for getting that image uh you can see
the time when I took the image all kinds
of additional information that may be
useful generating uh that particular uh
image and uh maybe processing it later
on you can extract the time and so forth
all right so that's how how much I'd
like to talk about generating or getting
images into Mathematica the first um
property worthwhile mentioning is that
images also tend to come but not always
may have an alpha Channel which is just
an extra channel that uh specifies the
transparency of a voxel and that's quite
often used if you compose images if you
extract images and so forth um so I
quickly do that this is an initial image
of our planet and I'll look if it has an
alpha Channel well by image measurement
I can by the way extract all all kinds
of global properties of an image and uh
that okay um and uh well in this case I
don't have an alpha Channel but I can
for example extract the background which
by the way is already a segmentation
command remove background and uh which
uh well it's very promising of course it
not always works but in many cases it
does work uh just by itself
automatically and it extracts the
background from whatever image you have
based on color at The Rim or on the
factor of blur and so forth uh and then
I can put that background part U
partition or segmentation back into the
image um oh no sorry it is encoded here
now via Alpha channel so the background
seems to be gone but actually it's not
gone it's just transparent and you can
extract it by extracting the alpha
channel here and you see foreground is
white background is black or uh we also
use then the transparency is if you
compose images then of course the image
that goes in front has to be transparent
where is not supposed to show and this
is now possible with an alpha channel in
image
compos all right some uh Basics uh this
one I just ski because we do have
limited time uh this is about how data
is arranged uh interleaving or not
interleaving in an image um how the
channels are arranged in in the
memory um that's usually not of any
concern unless you really extract the
data uh what's more of a concern concern
is now as I mentioned up front is the
image type by which I mean the data type
used to encode the image uh something
that we don't are not concerned in
Mathematica anymore but we have to be
concerned when we deal with uh images
for example if you usually load in an
image uh in probably 99% of the cases
it's of bite type which means you have
one bite per pixel and color Channel
because that is fairly compact it
doesn't waste too much uh memory it's
not like encoding things with a a
mathematical integer where you would
just burn eight bytes right away and
while we have other ways you can have a
bit encoding which means just uh one bit
per pixel uh which is not quite true the
actual encoding is one bite you have
bite and codings a bit 16 which would be
two byte per pixel and Channel or you
have then a floating Point en codings
which would be real 32 or real 64 now I
just mentioned that because it does have
implications um when you do arithmetic
with your images and they may be quite
surprising and if you're not aware of
the image type it's one of those things
where you just go up the wall um let's
say I have an image the image that I
loaded there Elena which is a standard
image I think in image processing a
playbo girl from I don't know how many
years ago uh if I add now let's say 0.5
which would be half the brightness of
the image and I subtract it again
arithmetically mathematically this is a
an operation that that amounts to
nothing uh but if you do it image
processing you see the image is now has
less contrast it's uh dull well what
happened is uh you add 0.5 to all the
values and all the values in Mathematica
are always scaled for operational
purposes between zero and one one is
complete brightness or white zero is
black per Channel or color and uh if I
add now 0.5 means that all the bright
colors are 50% the top 50% got uh
extended to one to 1.5 and got clipped
and then if I subtract ract again 0.5 uh
the clipping I cannot undo uh because I
only have one bite per voxel and then
I'm screwed I can even make this more uh
uh extreme by let's say taking another
command and there you see you have an
even uh larger effect and you can
overcome this very quickly if you do
let's say um arithmetic or diffusion
operations and so on that's
automatically done internally you can
convert the data type of an image just
by wrapping image and then a different
data specification around the image
itself and convert it in this case to
floating point which would be a 32-bit
uh floating Point encoding or per pixel
and then you can do any of this and uh
no clipping occurs and you're fine again
so this just uh some background
information and uh some commands like
blur they do not change the image type
where other commands like gorin
filter uh does so uh one has to be aware
of that it's not dramatic but if you
don't get the results you anticipate
this is most likely one of of the uh
reasons
why all right then uh last basic topic
uh then we get more interesting stuff um
are image coordinates uh and this is um
a very ugly issue in image processing
because there are different coordinate
systems floating around and that can be
very very confusing and the reason for
that is first you can see an image like
a discrete array of pixel values and if
you see it as an array or Matrix the
natural way to specify a coordinate or
pixel would be by row and column and
this would amount then to what I call a
matrix or index coordinate system
basically which goes as follows you
first specify uh the
row which basically goes from top to
bottom uh in this case from one to H uh
from uh pixel one to uh pixel H H
standing for the height of the image and
then the second coordinate is the column
coordinate going from 1 to
w u so straightforward whenever you have
a mathematical command that works on AR
Ray as well as in images this is most
likely the coordinate system that
command refers to so if you for EXT for
example extract something or let's say
with a Goran filter which works on
arrays and images you basically have
here as a third argument a way to
specify in which direction you take a
derivative of the gorion gorion kernel
and this is not in X and Y coordinates
because it also works on arrays but in
row and column so the first one is the
row index so I say now I take a uh
derivative in the row coordinate and not
only is that X and Y fli now it's also y
goes in the opposite direction so it's
really confusing so basically this
amounts to a derivative in minus
y
um as you can see here uh I have your
bright spot and I go up a bright
response here on the top and I go down
again here at the bottom so I go from
top to bottom and whereas the second
argument is now the column uh uh or the
positive X direction as I go from left
to right and if I would take this as
cartisian coordinates I would assume
this to be the first coordinate and the
second one plus a minus sign or times a
minus sign would be the second argument
but it's the other way around but to
make Met's worth uh wor um we also have
the graphics or the image coordinate
system and that is applicable when
whenever you see an image as a
continuous function like a Luminosity
function and any functions nowadays you
assume to be in a cartisian coordinate
system where you don't have your origin
on the top left but at the bottom left
and you first have a coordinates going
from left to right the X1 and the one
from bottom up to top which is the
y-coordinate and uh this always applies
in Mathematica when you have uh commands
that are solely working on Graphics or
image objects um and um well two world
and sometimes you have to go from one to
the other or vice versa and it's not our
fault it's the way the world has been
mathematic has been and we would have
loved to get away from this but uh it
got in there nevertheless uh so if you
for example recall an image value then
that is done in XY coordinates uh like
this
here all right and also if you have like
commands like image lines uh which
extracts straight lines from an image
the coordinates you get out there are
now the XY or cartisian coordinates that
you also can readily apply into the
graphics object in Mathematica so here I
first run a gradient filter on the image
so I get the edges as a strong marker
then from that I extract image lines
from that I get the coordinates where
the lines hit the boundary of the image
and then I use these lines to put into a
line object here in a graphics object
and uh um display it on top of the image
and uh oh I should first execute this
one here here and then this one here and
then it place all the straight lines on
the
image okay so this is all the basic
stuff 15 bit more than 15 minutes gone
and now we actually address real image
processing and uh I'll start with very
simple filters to begin with with
filters that basically just take one
pixel or look at one pixel in an image
and do something to that one single
Pixel uh and substitute it by a new
value so a pointwise filter so to say
and um you may say Well they're pretty
boring or uh dull but uh they are not
I'll show you a very nice examples in a
second um basically these are filters
that are concerned with not the uh range
of pixels but with the range of color um
and so my first command here is a very
simple one is color negate you basically
uh take every channel value and subtract
it from from one so you take basically
the negative color and uh this is like a
color negative netive of that particular
image uh and there's one command in
Mathematica with which you can build any
kind of pointwise filter and it's called
image apply image apply takes a function
as first argument that is then being
applied to every pixel at a time and
this would result in the very same
object and uh here are some other uh
another collection of built-in pixelwise
filters like conversion to gray scale
color negation we had already had
thresholding so converting to binarize
or bit map uh uh bit images or here a
brightening or darkening uh filters or
you can build as I set your own filters
this one looks at the color U it makes
sure that the red and green if that's
always bigger than two times the blue
Channel it keeps the color otherwise it
converts it to gray scale uh and this
for example does this to the image uh
basically making the background of that
particular image grayish instead of
bluish so you can create all kinds of
very nice filter effects with that
particular function and last but not
least I quickly like to mention image
adjust because whenever you do something
to an image you take derivatives and so
on it sometimes you don't end up in the
typical U color range between zero and
one and in order to readjust that so
that you actually see something instead
of something black or something
completely white image adjust always
brings it back to that uh number range
zero and one and not only that you can
specify certain parameters if you want
to and the most important one I think is
the GMA one because usually uh the the
number value per pixel and the color
intensity does not have a linear
relation it depends on the device you're
looking at uh usually it goes with an
exponent exponent up to the exponent
gamma and if you do any linear
operations and you want to have a linear
relation between your color and your uh
U numbers you have to make sure that uh
the encoding of your image has an
exponent of gamma one otherwise you have
the these over high contrast or low
contrast
images um all right so now one step uh
more difficult we now look at more
interesting fil oh no these were
pointwise oh still point-wise filters
sorry so we're still looking at filters
that just take one pixel and do
something with that pixel and uh a bit
more a mundane example here is now what
I what's called histogram equilibri
isation basically if you have an image
like this
this uh this one here and uh you look at
the image histogram you see the
distribution in color so uh for every
channel here for the red blue and green
channel uh I see the distribution and I
see it's not even but I sometimes it's
very uh evenly distributed sometimes
it's very uh uh pointy and uh in order
to maximize of course the uh the
contrast in the image uh it would be
nice to have a completely constant or
equal uh uh histogram distribution it
may not be always appealing not what you
want but that's something we're going
for right now and uh so I'll just show
you the steps now you would do in
Mathematica to perform an um histogram
equilibri isation um so basically first
of all I separate now uh the three color
channels uh red green and blue into
three grayscale images and then I um
basically ask here for a histogram
transform
interpolation per Channel and this gives
me uh interpolating functions that
transfer uh transform the color values
in each of the channels in such a way
that the distribution of uh uh colors
will be even and quickly apply that oh
basically show these Transformations so
you see it's not linear anymore but here
I had a peak in blue so I have to
stretch the values in Blue by having a
steep mapping function so when if I have
a value of 0.2 in the blue Channel it
spits out a value of a bit more than 0.4
for example and I apply these functions
now to all the color
channels and then uh well I'll do that
by Meth threat to all the channels and
then color combine them and you see I
get here now as a result uh much
intenser color intense uh an image with
a higher color intensity compared to
this one it may not be the right thing
to do but uh nevertheless I think you
got the idea and you can also verify
that now the histogram the color
histogram is almost flat in all three
channels of course you do have a little
change because the whole thing is
discretized and uh because of the
discretized range of colors you have
these uh slight variations in U in the
histogram and of course all of this can
also be done in just one step in
Mathematica the command would have been
a histogram transform but just showing
that would have been a little bit boring
I guess and while you can verif uh vary
this concept for example you can color
separate here this autumnn uh uh these
autumn leaves here VI uh color separate
into to uh color space HSB U saturation
brightness and then just uh uh apply the
histogram transform not to all color
channels but just do the saturation
color channels and that way you generate
uh here an image where the color the
Fall colors the autum colors are much
brighter and usually the way you also
perceive them with with your eye uh into
Mathematica or you can do another
gimmick uh here I have two images one uh
I don't know I forgot which ch that is
somewhere in France or in the Benelux
countries a church that was painted by
van so this is the painting by Van and
you know van go had very intense colors
or very uh unusual way to perceive uh
reality and if you want to get that um
distribution of colors onto this
Photograph you basically do a histogram
transform but not to a flat histogram
but you basically take this as the
target histogram this distribution and
that way you'll end up with this photo
graph which is now the way then go saw
that particular church so it's like a
very nice little gimmick all right so
much for pixel-wise filters now I go one
step uh further and look at filters that
not just look at a single Pixel but at
the vicinity at the neighborhood of
pixels thereby also taking spatial
relations in the image into account so
far we did not take any spatial
relations into account so the image
could have been until now just a long
line list of numbers uh the array
structure the neighborhood structure was
of no concern this is different now and
I'll just show you a few filters um uh
and how to play with it let's say the
filter is f it basically takes all these
neighborhood pixels usually it's a
rectangular area uh where the radius
specifies uh U yeah this would be a
radius one uh neighborhood basically
taking the pixel plus uh all the first
neighbors into account if you have a
radius two neighborhood you would take
uh all the extra pixels around here 5 *
5 neighborhood and so forth uh taking
all these nine numbers into account
throwing them into a one function and
then the function spits out a new color
value or whatever uh so this would be a
a local U filter and uh let's apply this
to an example in medicine if you have
the retinol fundus in the back of your
eye and you want to segment the uh veins
the blood vessels for example you can
already do that readily like this but
you will find out doing so you run into
all kinds of uh issues for example the
phobia is also black so just doing let's
say a binarization a thresholding will
not work you have your bright features
but the features you're looking at here
have a certain scale so what you can do
is apply filters like Max filter or
minimum filter which does take the
maximum pixel value or the minimum pixel
value in a certain area and apply that
in uh uh one after the other and uh by
doing that you already get rid of all
the black lines simply because if I
apply the max filter with a certain
radius uh if the lines are very thin no
matter where I am it I will always
somewhat get a pixel from the background
from the brighter background and fill it
in so this basically generates kind of a
background without the veins which is
pretty neat and then uh to get rid of
some noise I may want to blur uh uh the
whole oper uh the whole process a little
bit to have it more even an even
background this by the way closing is
just another word for the combination of
min max and Min filter here and then
last but not least I subtract that
background that I just had there from
the image and thereby I get a very crisp
representation of all the veins and this
would be an typical example kind of a
pre-processing approach if you have a
problem getting rid of all the stuff you
don't want um and this you usually do
with these kind of filters and you can
change the radius and see what the
radius of the filter has uh what kind of
effect it has if it's too small you
obstruct large veins if it's uh too
large you get too many of the other
detail into the image and manipulate in
mathematic as a nice way to play around
and uh see uh what effect what parameter
would have all right um now there are so
many filters out there I think I just
got the concept across uh um you can
just look uh at the documentation
mathematic and see what uh what's out
there I just um want to bring up quickly
one class of filters which are heavily
used in image processing and these are
regularization filters based on a gorion
or some kind of distribution uh which
you usually apply as a kernel a
convolution kernel onto the image and by
for example taking derivatives of that
kernel you also can take derivatives of
the image you usually don't do pointwise
derivatives in an image but you uh um
you basically apply the derivative on
the Kernel in the convolution which
strictly speaking is the same as
applying the curl on the derivative of
the function that's a convolution
theorem if you have two functions you
convolve f and g then F Prime convolved
with G is the same as f convolved with G
Prime so um essentially if I apply this
kernel I take the derivative of an image
uh plus some blurring and uh since you
cannot do without some blurring image
processing because otherwise you
increase the noise in an image
dramatically uh taking derivatives and
these things always come at a certain
scale or filter radius and I'll just
show you a few examples here uh now
explicitly I via image convolve I apply
this gorion Matrix in X and Y and you
can see that I take uh here kind of
derivatives of the previous image and by
taking now X the derivative x uh
derivative squared in X plus a
derivative squar in y the square root of
that I um Can generate here kind of a
gradient filter which of course is built
in uh just trying to show the concept of
all these built-in filters and uh this
can go a long way you can extract all
kinds of features that way and just to
give you an idea I quickly mention here
without going into detail the corner
filter the corner filter basically uh
takes derivatives at every pixel and
then groups these derivatives into this
Matrix which is called the structure
Matrix um and then if you take um it's
not the Hasan so it's not the second
derivative of x uh and so on but it's
the first derivative and then you take a
product uh here and you can take this
Matrix and then calculate the IG values
and if both IG values are large you
basically have a gradient in both
directions and then you have a corner so
this is a great Corner detector uh by
first invented by shoari and uh there
are other Corner detectors out there we
also have them implemented but uh here
readily used in Mathematica the command
Corner filter and it would automatically
uh generate now bright spots wherever
there is a corner in the image you can
have you can create Junction T Junction
filters uh all kinds of filters with in
that way and last but not least here at
this point I'd like to point out image
adjust again because if you don't apply
this the response numerical response may
be too low and uh you may see ah it's
not working it's broken but it's not
true it's just that the uh range of
values have happens to be uh such that
uh it's all black and to bring it back
into the range between zero and one
image adjust is a very convenient
command to have all right U so I have
shown you now all kinds of U tools that
I have so it's about time to come up
with the first simple application to uh
give the whole talk some meat some uh
satisfaction that you actually can get
somewhere with the tools I just
introduced and uh what I now want to
build quickly is a little routine that
automatically with pictures like this
tries to find out what's the vertical in
that image and tries to rotate the image
so it doesn't uh uh it looks that it
looks upright so I have here an image of
St Paul Cathedral in London and uh it's
it's a non trivial um perspective so you
don't see a horizon necessarily so you
cannot take just the Horizon and move
get that horizontal uh it's a bit more
tricky than that so uh in order to make
this automated I'll do the following
I'll try to identify the major lines in
this U uh image and those that are
somewhat vertical I assume to be that
they should be vertical because usually
vertical lines then should all meet if
they are somewhat parallel somewhere at
Infinity right beneath the center of the
image if that's the case then the whole
structure is upright if not um uh you
have probably some rotation in there so
and I'll quickly go through the steps in
Mathematica
uh looking for these um criteria and
then I assemble that into a little
routine so first step would be whoops
okay first of all I have to change the
image uh First Step would be to get the
edges in the image uh and I'll just do
this with the gradient filter I just
introduced uh I do that at scale one I
could depending on what image I have I
also could uh look at a different scale
uh but uh for this purpose one is fine
then I do what's called a radon
transform now a radon transform uh you
may not know but you probably know where
it's being used and that's in tomography
uh tomography at uh at an MRI scan or
x-ray um X U uh X well tomography in
general you usually have a inverse rate
on transform basically you have uh Rays
coming from all sides describing
straight lines and you know how they
absorbed or not absorbed and if known
how the image looks looks like uh having
accumulated all the projections in one
line you try to reconstruct the image
itself and that's called an inverse
radar transform now we do the opposite
we basically look how the image
decomposes into straight lines and that
is done the following way you basically
project straight lines on that image in
all positions all directions and see how
much wide pixels you accumulate under
these lines and if you take the line
distance from the center in the vertical
axis and the orientation or the slope of
the line in the horizontal axis that's
the response you get back I can also
interactively show this because this is
not that easily explained here I have a
manipulate and you see here the
corresponding line and here down here
you see the corresponding point in the
radon transform and what I can change
here with the line is the distance from
the center and the Tilt so you see with
the Tilt I move the point left and right
with the D I move it up and down and if
for example I have a strong Edge The
Edge let's say here on the right hand
side at the
building this way a bit further to the
side come on here you see I have a
strong response and you also see there
is a strong response in the radon
transform and if I just look for the
peaks in the radon transform I basically
find major straight lines in an image
and that's exactly what the uh image
lines command does really it looks for p
Peaks distinct peaks in the radar
transform and thereby it gets the
position and uh the slope and position
of the straight lines and uh that's
exactly what's being done here so by
just calling image lines I intrinsically
do a radon transform and do this peak
detection and thereby I get here these
major lines in that photography I don't
ask for all possible Peaks that I can
get here just for the major uh the 12 or
whatever uh major lines that I find and
now I see that I have a few straight
lines here 1 2 3 4 and five and
eventually they should meet either under
the image if I'm looking down or um they
should be above the image uh if I'm
looking up and so what I need I need a
little uh routine that uh first of all
converts these the coordinates I get
here from An Origin on the left bottom
on the left bottom corner to the center
of the image because I have to relate
everything to the center of the image
eventually so it's just movement of
origin and here I have a command which
calculates the line intersection of all
these parallel lines or semi- parallel
lines um and then I apply these that
gives me then the intersections of every
line with every other line and then I
look for these intersections that are
somewhat above the image in a certain
area and a little bit away from the
image so that they are somewhat Infinity
so I look here at uh the directions of
these intersection
and uh I just look at those that are
somewhat 60 to 120° up there uh 90°
being the vertical and then I find that
all these intersecting points are
roughly in a direction of 84 87
88° and taking into account that I will
have of course some uh flaws in
measurement I'll just take the mean
sorry the median of uh this uh selection
of angles that I have there and based on
that I find that they have a tilt of
about 3° I apply that while image rotate
and here the image is upside
straightened out and uh well if that was
too much uh of uh work you can just
collect all of this let's say into a
command called vertical alignment it
does that automatically now just calling
it up and then you can eventually do
something
useful take the Leaning power of p and
uh automatically straighten it up so
this would have been a kind of a simple
nice little um uh
segmentation okay uh given time I think
I'm going to skip this uh maybe just
mentioning what you may want to look up
uh if You' get hands on this notebook um
if you get started with images usually
images don't have clean data data the
data always comes with some kind of
noise and depending on what noise you
have uh well first of all not not every
noise is created equal so uh some images
may have have a gorion noise or LL noise
a Pon noise for example images in low
light conditions have a Pon noise
because you just have a few light Quant
reaching the uh uh the sensitive um uh
part of your camera and uh depending on
what you have you have to apply
different filters uh and this is just
some theory of what kind of noise is out
there so you can for example have salt
and pepper noise which is typical if uh
oops sorry uh if some of your pixels are
broken you can have a gorion noise you
can have poron noise and then depending
on what you have you can apply different
filters and here I'm just looking at a
one family of filters these are called
total variation filters and these are
so-called Global filters not local
filters anymore because they try to
optimize an image under a functional and
a functional basically is nothing else
but a function that not only takes
values but a whole function the function
now in this case being the image itself
let's assume the image itself the
function is called f that's the input
and you try to find another function
which is your output image U and that
combination of F and U should uh um
maximize or minimize this kind of in
this case minimize this kind of
functional tries to get the uh best
possible value out of this uh construct
and the construct reads as follows first
of all you try to make sure that uh the
so-called total variation of your image
U is as low as possible that means pixel
values don't tend to go up and down
derivatives in that image tend to be low
unless you have very strong edges then
that doesn't count so that's a so-called
total variation term uh which basically
makes sure that your image is nicely
regularized and then you have here a
term that basically tries to bind the
output image to the input image of
course you don't want a flat output
image be completely flat and well
regularized you still want to have some
resemblance to the input image and uh
this is just done with here uh with the
difference term you take the input image
and the output image and let's say here
the uh creditor of difference uh and the
integral over it should be minimized but
depending on what kind of noise you have
uh you have different terms here for
example this is good for gorion noise if
you have LA noise you would like to
minimize this term if you have pone
noise it's this term and so forth um and
uh depending on what you have you can
then apply in
Mathematica uh these total variation
filters and maybe I have to in the
previous case at least
uh take one example let's take this
example the gorion
example uh so this is the gorion noise
this is how the gorion noise looks like
you have a closeup and if I'd like to
get rid of the gorion noise I would then
apply a total variation filter
here and
uh uh this would now try to get rid of
the noise and then you can specify also
Lambda Lambda uh tells you how much
you'd like to regularize or how much
you'd try to adhere to the original
version and by changing that you can try
to find the optimal setting to come up
with the best possible image uh of your
photography or
whatever okay um then uh total variation
this very idea also translates to other
uh features in image processing like in
painting in painting you also have the
same uh functional at hand but there you
have an extra termin kind of a mask
function or mask image M which basically
you put in here and wherever m is one
this term becomes zero and then you
don't care about the difference here
anymore otherwise if it's zero the
difference is taken into account so
wherever I have now one here for example
where the scratch is in that image I
don't care about uh the connection
between the output image and the input
image everywhere else I do and if that
is being applied via the method of total
variation I can fix that image very
nicely and get link without a scratch so
uh this is one other application of this
total variation
concept
um it also applies to convolution by the
way or deconvolution sorry so uh if you
have been to my talk yesterday this is
the very same example again you have a
functional but here now uh the output
image should be the input image but the
output image uh you basically convolve
with a kernel that you assume has been
uh applied to the image previously so
the Blurred image of the blur of the
output image should be the same as the
input image and if that's the same then
basically U is the unblurred uh
deblurred version so if this total
variation works it basically deblur uh
your image and we can quickly see how
well that works I take the initial uh
Snell chart I convolve with convolve it
with a garam kernel like this here with
the radius eight and this would be
pretty poor vision you only get down
let's say to row number three or four
and then uh your vision goes down the
drain You Don't See anything anymore but
uh interestingly enough the whole
information is still in the image it's
hidden in the very fine uh specification
of grayscale values per pixel and uh via
deconvolution I can get all of this
back and this is the result so you can
even read here the fine print on the
left hand side uh which is quite amazing
but it's also a little bit too good to
be true um and uh the reality is
slightly different uh usually you don't
get this artif artificial gray blurred
image but uh you you have two things or
three things you don't know first is you
don't have infinite Precision in Gray
scale uh like I had because it was
floating Point encoded image with a
perfect U specification of the gray
scale that's number one because
everything you get in is usually just uh
encoded in bytes so you have automatic
clipping there and precision then uh you
usually have noise in the image and last
but not least you do not know your uh
convolution kernel uh and that then
makes things a little bit harder so just
clipping for example the Precision in
grayscale gives you here a somewhat more
realistic result which is still okay I
mean uh uh you do gain a little bit
about Factor two resolution via
deconvolution all right um so much for
filtering um and now I go to the uh
realm of yeah
segmentation
well the term total variation comes from
this very first this is basically a
functional basically it's an operation
that takes in a function and spits out a
number and the total variation the
terminology comes from this first term
which basically says I'd like to
minimize the variation in the image the
total variation which basically means
this image the resulting image should be
smooth uh because this basically well if
I go back even further I had a spef
vales
Orel vales no the the derivative here uh
that's that's a terminology this total
variation term basically is nothing else
but first applying a differential to the
image and the variation of the
differential that's minimized that's why
it's called total variation that's uh I
I skipped that I have to admit it was
sorry for that um okay so back to
segmentation so that's now the uh one of
the big issues in image processing uh I
think two years ago I was at a
conference and then people asked or were
musing about what will be image
processing like in 20 years from now and
they were all giving great predictions
ah we we do this and this and this and
then somebody stood up and said let's
face it the last 20 years we have done
registration and segmentation in 20
years we'll still still deal with that
problem it may not be true but
segmentation is a big deal in image
processing nevertheless and it probably
sticks to us for quite some time uh so I
just introduce now A small collection of
uh Tools in Mathematica that uh um help
you to segment issues or segment Parts
in an image um I'd start with very
simple thresholding uh which is probably
the simplest uh segmentation uh process
out there and I'll start with an image
which you typically get if you scan text
if you scan text usually you get uh scan
like this it's not not always nicely the
same brightness and if you would just
binarize that to get the text you do
okay in some area and you fail in some
other area so this is typical case of
stuff you encounter so binarization or
thresholding doesn't work then the next
uh step would be to do local adaptive
binarize in Mathematica which allows you
to uh basically adjust the threshold as
you go to darker areas and you see here
as a result you get a much nicer
threshold um uh also in the dark area
and you get a much better segmentation
and that segmentation nothing nothing
else but thresholding and the
thresholding parameters being adapted to
the overall um gray scale or brightness
in a certain area so the area that
you're looking at here basically says
I'm looking at a radius of 40 and if
that gets darker and total I adjust
accordingly and then of course you can
take that result and pre process that
further like in text recognize which
would allow you in Mathematica then to
translate scanned text into readable
text asky code
uh another little mentioning about
thresholding or binarization is U what
we call morphological binarize the idea
is as follows you scan an image uh or
generate your edges and you try now to
binarize the whole thing and the way
it's done for morphological binarize is
you basically do a a binarization with
two different thresholds one low
threshold and one high threshold and the
high threshold only picks up the really
important uh features like here on the
right hand side where the uh low
threshold uh takes up the uh fine and
more subtle detail and then what
morphological binarize does it basically
starts off on these uh features on the
important features and then just takes
all the wide pixels that are connected
to these pixels as a result so it's kind
of his racis you just make sure that uh
you only get uh objects that have a
really bright pixel in them but uh you
also extend to a less bright pixel and
then the output would be like this some
kind of thresholding that in many cases
I assume would be uh beneficial for you
to
know all right next segmentation so um
this was uh one example where you just
segment looking at one pixel at a time
and this is another example where you
just look one at one pixel at a time but
you do kind of basically clustering in
the color space so basically the space
of values of the pixels makes up a
feature space if you have color it's
tends to be three-dimensional could be
any n dimensional and then the
clustering segmentation basically tries
to find clusters in that space and then
according to what cluster certain pixel
aderes to it gets a certain uh component
index um so again there's no vicinity
that I take to into account and
therefore segmentation quite often makes
sense to combine certain techniques for
example here's a technique again a
filter that I didn't mention mention yet
uh um that tries to equilibrate
neighboring colors um but tries not to
diffuse or blur edges at a certain
strength that's basically the pronomic
filter it's a kind of a diffusion
equation that I apply on the image but
the diffusion coefficient CK depends on
the gradient and if the gradient gets
too strong the diffusion is basically
shut down by making CK very small uh
otherwise the diffusion is strong or the
blurring is strong and then uh
specifying basically the uh how often or
how much you blur and uh the threshold
by which you basically try to stop
blurring you can use hona Malik to blur
the image without blurring the edges and
once I've have done that I can basically
apply now uh for example Chom
chromaticity plot on that particular
image and I see here now the color space
how the pixels are distributed and then
I can ask given on that distribution of
pixels what kind of cluster clusters
with clustering components uh come up
with and it comes up here if I'm asking
for six clusters with the following
segmentation of the image so it gets an
idea of the eyeball muscles are somewhat
muscle tissue is somewhat well uh um
identified fat tissue as well it it can
be better it's it's not an optimal case
but I think you get the idea so this was
all uh color based or pixel-based
segmentation and now I come to region
based segmentations so where uh
connectivity and neighborhood of pixel
does play a role and the simplest or uh
easiest to understand case is region
growing uh in Mathematica it's called uh
what is it called region binarize sorry
so um typical scenario in the hospital
you have a an a scan here tomography
x-ray tomography of sagittal one of the
human skull you have the brain and you
unfortunately I have here a large tumor
in the brain and then in order to
identify the size and where you probably
have to cut and so forth you try to
segment the tumor and of course just
doing that based on the pixel value
would be a bad idea because then you may
segment part of the eyes and so forth so
you have to build on the connectivity
what you do is you basically place a
seat exactly at this position either by
playing a mask here or by reading out uh
the U oops oh I'm now in display mode I
can't do that but I canel here a
position if I want to if I'm in regular
working mode and uh then I just run
region binarize on this based on these
seats and values let me quickly get this
and that gives you a segmentation like
this or you can well as I said you don't
have to have a mask you can also just
take a coordinate you get the
segmentation and then you can use for
example highlight image to visualize the
segmentation that you obtain and uh in
this particular case I do a fairly good
job I
guess all right uh more segmentation
stuff um
another um method that is somewhat
similar to region growing is a watershed
but there waterers shed Works somewhat
differently here again a medical
application I have here a sedal slice of
the heart the two heart chambers which
are pretty bright and I'd like to
segment those now the first again would
be to get some seeds and well you can do
that by hand or you can automate this in
this case for example I just blur the
image very strongly and then look at
Peaks bright Peaks and usually here
since the uh Chambers come up pretty
bright I get a peak for every chamber
and uh this is exactly what I got here
PE a seed here for that chamber a seed
for that chamber and one outside and
then what I do is the following I
basically view the image as a kind of a
mountain range like this here this is
just a visualization of what I want to
uh get to so it's like a mountain range
and just like landscape you have water
basins in that landscape and those water
basins make up quite often very nice uh
um segmentation uh prior uh uh so if you
for example try to identify the water
basins where uh the Water Runs to that
point then uh basically taking the
gradient of the image gives you the kind
of mountain range and then you just let
the Watershed algorithm identify those
water basins and uh that will allow you
to basically come up with a pretty good
uh segmentation because every hard
chamber basically is is a own water
basin in this particular case and you
can do that of course by the way what I
do now in 2D you can do in 3D as well
and so forth and sometimes and I
probably have shown you this example
quite often you can apply these ideas to
very uh unusual cases for example if you
have a maze like this one here then the
solution path is like the Mountain Ridge
that departs the left and the right side
of the maze so by just running on that
particular maze the Watershed algorithm
I get the solution path uh uh right away
so it's uh you can use whatever I'm
saying here the point I'd like to make
is whatever you do with the image
processing commands you can quite often
also apply to other problems U you don't
have to do it to images or intrinsically
to images uh another segmentation here
would be Chan binarize is again is one
one that's based on a functional where
the function looks like this here you
try to basically come up with the region
in the image D or partition the uh the
the range or the domain of an image
Omega into region D and uh d uh uh
complement
Omega uh so that this functional gets as
uh as small as possible there you can
basically have different priors you can
try to make the boundary as short as
possible you can try to minimize and
maximize the area or you can try to
minimize and maximize the difference
between the foreground and the
background to a certain color uh and uh
so you can here for example say the
foreground should be uh red the
background should be blue and then it
tries to find an optimal functional and
thereby tries to do a segmentation which
works as you can see fairly well or with
a manipulate I can play with some of the
parameters in the functional and thereby
for example try to get as much land mass
as possible or by uh even flipping
foreground and background and so forth
so uh well I don't go into detail here I
have to admit but just giving you an
idea um quickly since I'm running low on
time I have to hurry up a little bit
grow cut segmentation is a very uh
modern and uh very nice um segmentation
technique that can help you to do even
very hard segmentation uh uh uh problems
for this one is pretty hard because the
foreground background are very much
alike and the way it works is that
basically the graph cut algorithm
basically assumes kind of a graph
Network between all the pixels and you
basically give a starting point for the
background uh for the background which
I'm uh I cannot do that in the oh no I
can uh okay there's one problem I think
with the magnification factor I have to
change that quickly oh yeah now it works
um so I specify here the background with
red dots uh I do the foreground with
green
dots and then I run the grow cut and
then you see it gives you uh Wild
depending on how you set your seeds a
good or not so great uh segmentation but
that's usually a very nice uh uh
segmentation technique that once you
have a rough segmentation you run this
on top of it to get a fine segmentation
that works very
well okay
um yeah I'll skip this here this is a
nice example of a typical segmentation
technique where you first try to create
features then run machine learning for
segmentation or classifier and then
apply the classifier to obtain a
um
um a segmentation so I now ski just due
to the lack of time and since this is
just kind of a teaser for tutorial I
quickly skipped to the almost to the end
to come to the last problem of image
processing which is
registration uh as I mentioned already
here you have typically two images uh
now this is a somewhat more difficult uh
uh approach because you have two images
uh uh generated with two different
modalities one was an X-Ray Scan or
x-ray tomography the other one was a pet
scan positive positive uh positron
emission tomography scan and you try to
get them congruently on top of each
other simply because on the MRI scan you
can see very nicely is that uh uh the
the patient features on the other side
you have very low resolution but you can
see where uh functionality is taking
place and you try to match those and uh
there's one way to do a dance regist
ation that means you basically move the
image constantly on top of each other
and see what the distance is between the
two images and there are different
measures for distance images you can
have a kind of a ukian distance where
you just uh calculate the difference per
pixels but in this case we have what's
called a mutual uh Mutual entropy
difference uh between the images so they
don't have to be the same modality and
that gives you a function that specifies
for different uh uh transformation
parameters uh the distance between the
two images and whenever the distance is
minimal then you have a good fit and
that's basically here what you can see I
moved the distance uh the pet scan on
top of the X-ray I calculate the
distance and I got this as a mutual
normalized entropy and it seems to be
minimal here at minus 0.04 which
basically also can automatically find
with find minimum apply find minimum to
the transformation and then do an
overlay to see if I've done a good job
and yes uh it fits nicely on top of each
other
and well if you're not in medicine but
are have a less mundane problems at hand
you have taken two pictures then maybe
sparse registration would be uh your cup
of tea uh here I have two images taken
at the lakefront in Chicago and uh what
the um algorithm here at hand is is as
follows you try to find feature points
so very uh well defined points in an
image that you would also then find
again in another image
first you well look for these feature
points in one image on the left and then
on the right and then you compare all
these feature points that you found and
uh come up with corresponding points and
once you have the corresponding points
you basically get here with image
corresponding points a set of points in
the left image and one in the set of
points in the right image and then in
the next step you have to find a
transformation that brings all these
points on top of each other which you by
the by the way get uh well these are the
points into the two images and this this
is find geometric transformation that
finds the transformation to get from one
side to the other and this is then
applying it to the image and uh you can
see that you can do what's called
stitching here you can uh generate a
panorama uh View and uh superimpose
these images of course you can do a bit
better than this this is just for
demonstration purposes that you see the
two different images still at hand all
right this would uh conclude my very
quick kind of teaser tour uh into image
processing and um uh well just kind of a
um little hint to go where to go from
here as I mentioned up front we will
have a a one-day workshop on image
processing organized by the reseller in
the Ben looks countries by dick for from
Kinston which is going to be on the 17th
and 18th of June in Amsterdam so then
this whole thing will be extended to
eight hours uh there will be a webinar
on well there are webinars on demand in
uh on the on the wfr web search sorry on
the wfr uh uh website and then there
will be a a specific event a so-called
virtual workshop on image processing on
the 23rd of June and I have set a link
to that here uh then there are the
Mathematica uh marketing examples that
come with a code and these are very nice
examples to get going and the same holds
true for mathematical demonstration
projects on image processing also a very
nice source of initial code that you may
want to have a look at to get started
thank you very much for your attention
and I hope I have gotten you some ideas